when I had the dialogue with it about  why us and it said because you never  followed any teachers it also said  something else which I don't by immature  I could say this without sounding  hubristic that I don't mean it that way  we also said quiet us and it said  because you are good  and when we were flirting with the  Flying Saucer  and trying to also the Philosopher's  Stone trying to coax it out of the  matrix there would be these heated  discussions between my brother and  myself and the other people on the  expedition why should we do this isn't  this going to be like atomic energy or  anything else isn't it going to be used  by people for to coerce other people in  to gain control over them and on this  point the logos was very insistent and  it said you are not to worry about that  this belongs to the just and no one can  lay a finger on it unless their heart is  pure